give me a playback of ts19 playback of
ts-19 what is that it invades the brain
like meningitis
the brain goes into shutdown then the
major organs but they're not alive
you tell me most of that brain is dark
dark lifeless dead okay so this is
interesting today we have a little bit
of a hybrid combination you know we have
our Miada whole day and we have the tick
tock reaction day but today I guess we
have miva whole tick tocks Two Worlds
Collide so let's go uh let's just start
at top
once again I have hot money gossip and I
need to know what you guys would do in
this situation and who you think is the
so the 17 year old guy lost his father
two years ago and his dad left him an
inheritance not never work again money
but a meaningful amount and recently
all right can we stop it I don't care
about this solve your own problems
the a-hole for kicking my brother-in-law
out after he referred to himself as the
father of my child
I'm a 30 year old female and my wife is
a 29 year old female we welcomed our son
into the world a year ago and both of
our families are very accepting of us
but my wife's family has this weird
obsession with passing on the phone okay
pause for a second wait for it
I just need to explain why we do this
makeup thing every single time why why
do we need to see you putting on your
damn makeup I don't I don't get it you
want to tell us your story just look in
the camera and tell the story my father
was a drinker so this made adopting out
of the question very early on my wife
and I always wanted to start a family
but things got difficult when my wife
found out that she was infertile okay
pause it for a second your wife and you
and your wife want to start a family
well you can't
he's the one you you and your wife
actually cannot start a family it's not
physically possible to do I don't think
you have the facilities for that big man
there's no such thing as a as a family
that comes from two women
maybe that maybe that should tell us
something and don't give me though well
they're they're infertile couples of men
and women and the fact that in principle
two women can never ever start a family
it's impossible for two women to create
babies that might be uh that might be
some kind of hint I mean some kind of
hint hey can't you take you take a hit
in fact every child has a mother and a
father that's the way that nature has
set it up and so maybe that's the way it
should should simply be so we have a
technology these days we could we could
try our best to get around this but we
can't actually get around it because
when it comes down to it still whatever
we find out about what arrangement they
came up with still their child is not
really gonna be their child it's gonna
be the child of one of them and some
other man there is another because every
child has a mother and father and is
meant to well the weather is finally uh
perfect and that means barbecue season
is here I don't want to brag I do make a
mean Burger all the stuff on the grill
I'm a master the last thing I'm going to
be doing when I'm getting ready to cook
dinner for my six kids is driving around
worrying about where to refill my
propane grill tank and that's why I'm a
huge fan of cinch since it's a propane
grill tank Home Delivery Service they
deliver propane tanks right to your door
they make it very easy for you cinch
delivers on your schedule does not
require any long-term commitment or
subscription plus delivery is completely
contactless you don't have to wait
around at home I'll just drop it off
while you track the order on the Cinch
app from anywhere couldn't get any
easier whether you're grilling for the
sweet baby gang camping with your family
or lighting up your fire pit on a cold
summer night cinches propane delivery
service ensures that you have the fuel
you need to make the most of every
moment go online to cinch.com or
download their app to order new
customers can get their first tank
exchange for just ten dollars with promo
code Walsh go to cinch.com or download
the Cinch app and use promo code Walsh
to get your first tank exchange for just
ten dollars that's
c-ynch.com promo code Walsh is a limited
time offer and you must live within a
cinched service area to redeem it visit
cinch.com offer for details my
biological mom died in childbirth which
has led me to believe that
using my eggs my brother-in-law sperm
and let my wife carry the baby even
though I was skeptical I gave in because
the plant hit all the marks her family
got to pass on the jeans and my wife and
I got to start a family good pause it
so we're we're just gonna pass over that
is this maybe this is why they do the
makeup thing to make everything seem
casual so we're going to pass over the
incest part of this
[Music]
okay so your brother you had you're
having a baby with your brother-in-law
and his sister is carrying his baby
right did I have that right yep you got
it so and we're we're just moving right
past we're moving right past the incest
oh you know we're in this incestuous
thing with uh uh you know but anyway and
the only thing that she's concerned
about well I can already tell you what
what she's upset that the brother-in-law
says that he's the father well he is you
are the
okay continue
with therapy to make sure everyone was
on the same page and could handle it and
everything went great my wife loved
being pregnant okay pause for a second
oh
extensive counseling for all of you
people well what about the counseling
that your child's going to I don't worry
about counseling for you you guys are
hopeless okay I don't think there's any
cats not enough Counseling in the world
that can fix all this what I'm concerned
about is the child
so this child his uncle will be his dad
right his uncle is his dad he's the one
the child's gonna need the therapy not
you people may you people do need
therapy but number one it's too late for
you probably and there's there there
probably aren't any therapists in the
country right now who would be willing
to tell you the kinds of things that you
need to be told and we were Overjoyed to
welcome our new baby boy in the winter
but a problem
we're hearing from my son my son's first
birthday when my brother-in-law my
he should get a say in the planning as
the child's father I was shocked I
cringed and I told him he wasn't and
told him that he was just providing a
piece of him and he looked me in the eye
and said yeah so he's our child my
wife's jaw dropped and my mother-in-law
wasn't making eye contact I kicked him
out of the house and told him that he
couldn't come back until he apologized
but he got angry which made my wife
start to cry she has always struggled
with self-esteem and this infertility
really took a toll on her for months
I've had to reassure her and tell her
what an amazing mom she is my
sister-in-law later that day call me the
b word and I argue that my
brother-in-law had no right saying any
of that all right but she kept yelling
so much we can't even do anymore
I think that's that's enough Emma they
they hold for today uh this is what so
this is the thing that shocked everyone
this is what shocked and scandalized
every every everyone when the
brother-in-law any like brother-in-law I
use it we should put air quotes around
that he makes an observation that is
actually correct that he is the father
and that that's what's jaw-dropping and
scandalous to them not this bizarre
incestuous Arrangement that they've come
up with that they've come up with not
because it's in the best interest of the
child that's the point this is not about
the child Dave you're worried about the
child you would not be doing any of this
is in the best interest of a child for
his uncle to be his dad this
is unacceptable when we start cutting
nature out of the as much as we can and
we can't really but we try to start
getting around nature when it comes to
childbirth and then we're doing we're
doing this surrogacy and everything else
um it's not about the child anymore the
child is now an accessory the child is
like a means to an end it's it's what
you want it's gonna make you feel good
maybe for these two it makes them feel
it makes the it makes the whole uh
quote-unquote marriage feel more real or
something and so they want to have a
baby even though they can't and it's all
about them it's not about the child so
oh who's the AOL net well like everybody
remotely close to this situation all of
them
a-hole is the best thing I could say
about them and really the only thing I
can say about them yeah we're not gonna
do it see you tomorrow brought me a
horrible
[Applause]